foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
proud and do not give a [ __ ]
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [ __ ] them
[Music]
good morning and morning and morning
[Music]
Thursday October 20th
I have some bad news
Gabe Sanchez will not be joining us
today either I'm very sorry he's very
sorry
look he's on set filming an ad for the
Soros Media Group it's a deep State ad
for the Soros medical Medical Group not
media medical it's a medical thing
no he's he really is on set filming
today so he will not be joining us here
on the show
yesterday today I believe I believe
he'll definitely be here for bonehead I
believe tomorrow
we have to have Gabe Sanchez for
bonehead how in the hell would we do the
bonehead without Gabe's engines
because today is Thursday the poll for
bonehead of the week comes out today
here on the Tony Michaels podcast
and then tomorrow we go through bonehead
of the week and if you want to vote for
bonehead Elite make sure to hit that
subscribe button right now on YouTube
you can vote on YouTube on the community
tab do you know where the community tab
is
you just go to the channel it says
Community you hit that one there's the
poll
so you can vote on YouTube you can also
vote on Twitter at Tony Michaels pod
follow us there for the bonehead of the
week poll
later on this afternoon this evening
depending on where you're at Laurel
and then tomorrow in the second hour as
we do every single Friday we will go
through your vote
because you cast your ballot for bone
end of the week you decide we go through
it every single Friday in the second
hour of the show so I apologize
um Gabe Sanchez has some deep state
work to do today
um with the if he's filming on set
for the Soros Medical
group
oh I was gonna say something about
chlamydia but he was like no no no
it's the it's the Soros Medical Group
and I definitely would not ever suggest
on an open hot mic
that he's doing a PSA for chlamydia or
something I would never suggest that
ever
wouldn't do that
to my Greek Sanchez you guys love Gabe
here and uh he was he was uh he was
saddened that he wouldn't make it
yesterday and today but he's working you
know
when you get out there and you you do
auditions you have to work
and what a great what a great gig to get
a deep State gig for the Soros Medical
Group
it's a fantastic gig
to have
I I really don't know what he's filming
to be quite honest I know he's filming
something today on Set uh
I'm making all this up
as I do every day hate Watchers they
accuse me of making stuff up and lying
that's what they say
they'll type it out and they'll tweet it
to me you're a liar you make stuff up
where's your evidence I mean literally
the entire show almost the entire show
is me talking about video footage
or like a tweet that some dumb [ __ ]
tweeted I don't know what to tell you
what the [ __ ] you want me to do
I mean I'm just here to show you the
[ __ ] that's all I'm here to do make it a
little cathartic give you direction as
far as what it means to our democracy
and how the hell you can use it as a
sledgehammer to save democracy that's
all I'm here to do
truth not truth well [ __ ]
I mean if you can't handle the truth
and then don't come here
and I'll tell you I don't think these
are not I don't make this [ __ ] up this
is an AI
we don't make the videos up here I don't
go out and find them I'm not some
[ __ ] beat reporter either
I take what's in the news boneheads
and I just show it to you
because I believe that sunlight is the
best disinfectant we have to expose
these [ __ ]
and uh Howard Stern gave his opinion on
Kanye West this morning and he said as
much in his little rant about Kanye
that the media is giving him attention
but Howard also said that they're
exposing him
which is what is happening and he's
destroying his entire [ __ ]
Legacy
as far as his art is concerned and he's
destroying what career he would have in
the future
at least for the next five to seven
years
I mean I believe there's another
interview out there where Kanye West has
asked are you being anti-semitic and he
says yes like without giving a Beat
the guy can't stop saying Jews and
Jewish media and Jewish Bank he can't
stop saying it
he's he's [ __ ] brainwashed and Howard
also goes on to say about the uh his
mental his mental health state
which I talked about that but that's no
[ __ ] excuse for him to say this
garbage and really it's no excuse for
Candace Owens and her [ __ ] husband
now farmer the guy the CEO of parlor
it's no excuse for them to coerce him
into this situation where he's going to
absolutely lose every single bit of his
livelihood and really it couldn't happen
it could happen to a better guy
come on
give me a [ __ ] break Kanye West has
enough money he could just disappear and
live the way he wants to live and never
have to [ __ ] work another day in his
life why are we [ __ ] concerned about
it the reason why is because he has an
amplifier
that he has a [ __ ] megaphone
and it's not just like a megaphone into
the world of politics that's what
they're trying to do is they're trying
to creep this [ __ ] into other parts of
our [ __ ] culture is what they're
trying to do
and it appears to have some breakthrough
I mean otherwise no one would be [ __ ]
listening to Kanye
Chris Cuomo wouldn't be doing [ __ ]
interviews with Kanye with his
half-assed cell phone in his car when
it's dark outside
and them arguing about what his [ __ ]
name is I'm not [ __ ] you on there
they argue about what his name is
on that interview if you go watch the
extended version it's really [ __ ]
dumb like it's really stupid they spend
three minutes Chris Cuomo is such a
[ __ ] now Chris Cuomo has pushback he
and that's what should happen is there
should be pushback on Kanye here
and there's plenty of it
and I think it's a miscalculation really
uh by the anti-semites the America First
Nazi party
to think that oh this will be a good
thing if we get this message out there
in these places that it wouldn't
normally exist
folks the majority of the country
doesn't listen doesn't listen to
politics they don't they don't give a
[ __ ] they don't know anything about it
nor do they care they should
they absolutely should but they don't
and there's nothing you're going to do
to change it not a goddamn thing besides
yelling screaming you know
beat something at the end of the bar you
know like with a machete or something to
get their attention that's the only way
you're going to get their attention
that's what Republicans do that's what
they've always done
is yell and scream and carry on
create crises that don't exist
solutions for problems that aren't
problems
that cause more crisis to have more
solutions for problems that aren't
problems Jesus Christ there is a g I'm
going to talk about this today
and this news clip of this story Jesus
Christ there is a GOP candidate a
moglodyte
I think it's somewhere in Arizona I
believe I know it doesn't [ __ ] matter
does it matter where it's at
this point these people are [ __ ]
crazy it doesn't matter what state what
county they're in or what office they're
running for this guy's running for some
kind of college uh Community Education
board or some [ __ ] I don't know
again doesn't really [ __ ] matter
they're out of their [ __ ] minds
this guy gets caught at a preschool on
on the same campus
beating off his wiener in his truck to
porn
then the cops catch him
and his his responses that I [ __ ] up
and I [ __ ] up
but this is because their brains can't
function
without some kind of fake ass crisis I'm
sure this guy is he listens to Matt
Walsh
that that [ __ ] [ __ ] box
marginalizing already a marginalized
Community like trans children
John Oliver did a great piece
um on his show Last Week Tonight
about uh transgender
people and there was a little girl on
the story
and Matt Walsh [ __ ] bigot
oh man I wish I I probably shouldn't
wish this but one of these days if I'm
within spitting distance of Matt Walsh
um
Matt Walsh goes on to absolutely
absolutely dehumanized dehumanize
that little girl on his show
intentionally
so is it surprising that Maga
Republicans are getting caught in their
pickup trucks beating off the porn
because all they can think about is
children's genitalia and what bathroom
they go to I'm not [ __ ] you that is
Matt Walsh's entire personality is how
many how how young they can be to marry
them what's in their pants
and what bathroom they can use I'm not
[ __ ] you his entire personality he
doesn't even know what a woman is he had
a he had a [ __ ] run around the
country asking people because he doesn't
know
he has no idea what's a woman please
tell me please tell me what a woman is
so is it surprising that Maga
Republicans these America First Nazis
are getting caught
masturbating in a pickup outside a
preschool nope not surprising not one
not not in the least
foreign
not surprising at all I'm not against
masturbation or porn really for that
matter I mean I don't know what kind of
porn this guy was watching
but I'm not against consensual adult
porn
not
I'm not against masturbating to it
are flicking your bean do it all right
whatever you want to do you should
probably do it in the privacy of your
own home though I mean
that's the thing you should probably do
if you're going to you're going to use
uh porno
just saying you might want to do it in
privacy not out in the open where
everyone can see you doing it probably
not a thing you want to do
but they have a really tough time
they're really tough go about it
a really tough go about it
I mean their entire their entire party's
personality
now is hating
transgender people
like literally that is their end Jews
and the Jewish the Jewish media right
like that's their entire personality
send the Jews back to Israel and we want
to get rid of transgender people
it's your entire [ __ ] personality oh
yeah and gas prices they can't
they can't figure out how [ __ ] Gas
Works
but gas prices gas prices
genitalia and send the Jews back to
Israel that is their entire their entire
personality at this point
and you're wondering why when they have
these [ __ ] Nazi rallies that Grandpa
Poopypants shows up at and he spews his
anti-Semitism and his hatred into a
microphone
you're wondering why the people there
get dumber and dumber and dumber come on
it's not hard to understand
yeah Baron says his best here
it's milk too milk as if milk and gas
are the same thing right
they have no idea that milk and gas are
two different markets no [ __ ] clue
and they don't know
they don't know that the reason why milk
is so goddamn high is because of their
[ __ ] orange Mussolini Jesus and the
trade deals that he made with Canada no
clue has they have no [ __ ] idea
why would they
why would they have to form a decent
argument around the crisis that they
create
foreign
why would they I mean literally they
went on for an entire summer about
critical race theory in schools
a thing that does not exist in
elementary schools it's really [ __ ]
dumb it was really [ __ ] stupid
and a lot of the countries stood back
and went what the [ __ ] are they talking
about and some of some of the countries
like CRT what's that holy [ __ ] you mean
they're teaching our white children to
feel guilty no no they're not it's a
college course you dummy
and if you're talking about teaching
kids history and proper history like
Christopher Columbus did not is it did
not and is not a founding father for oh
man
who to thunk it
it's really it's not hard
to say the truth
it's not hard to show the truth
they just don't want to believe it
and that's the problem that they have
it's because they're
they're inherent bigotry
their belief system their entire world
view is torn apart by the truth
and it really pisses them off
so what they decide to do instead
is to just believe whatever they feel is
best to believe
why not
sounds pretty good to me
right
why would they give a [ __ ] about the
facts of the truth
and really it's the best way to project
anyways oh my God it's the best way for
them to project
to just to to just literally take
an issue
that you can simply track down the truth
it's not very [ __ ] hard
hey like this Oklahoma debate the
Governor of Oklahoma doesn't know that
his state has a higher crime rate than
other states
he thinks because there is more crimes
reported in higher populated areas that
his crime rate is lower it's really
[ __ ] dumb
he doesn't even know he doesn't even
know
and he's standing on stage I'll show you
I'm going to show you that clip too we
got all kinds of Clips played today
but this is their this is their [ __ ]
sickness this is the Q Anon sickness
that has leaked into their brains like
Laura Logan
it's all over today like this is all
interconnected folks
the Laura Logan thing has everything to
do with the governor's race and that
debate everything all of it it has to do
with each other because there is a
disease in our country it's a [ __ ]
disease
and it's metastasized inside the
Republican party and now there are the
America First Nazi party
every [ __ ] one of them has succumbed
to the the Q Anon cancer
of the brain
I mean [ __ ] they're in the chat here
turn Chat every goddamn day why do you
think they're yelling and screaming
again about gas prices milk children's
genitalia and bathrooms and CRT
when you got when you have
a cancerous disease inside your brain it
doesn't allow it to function very well
your reality is a little skewed you're
probably deluded
deranged unhinged
and you always fall back on your number
one God and religion
speaking of God and religion and people
who fall back on it Mike Pence
you see this clip he was asked and we're
gonna I'm gonna again I'm gonna show
this clip too he was asked
would you vote
how they ask him if he'd vote for Donald
Trump
it's really not a tough question
there's only one there's only one answer
there's only one correct answer it is no
that's the correct answer I mean as long
as your pro-democracy the answer is no
if your four authoritarianism then it
may be something other than that
anything other than no you have you have
some sort of
you just you you like authoritarianism
to some degree
and you like buffoonery to some degree
because when anyone ever asks you the
question would you vote for Donald Trump
no no like you don't even have to get
through the Trump part no absolutely
[ __ ] not
I mean that might be a better answer
than no absolutely [ __ ] not
I don't know it just it's weird that he
that he would give such a weak answer
but it's not surprising
I think he's I think he's trying to say
that he's gonna run for president
Mike we don't like you and by we I mean
pro-democracy people don't like you
you're a [ __ ] scumbag Mike Pence
you're not a hero no matter what anyone
says about you you're not a [ __ ] hero
and the and the Trump ludites the
moglodytes the Trump supporters they
want to hang you dude
so I I don't think it's not gonna you
running it's probably not a good idea
but the answer to the question Mike
Pence if you want to know what the
answer to the question is
it's absolutely [ __ ] not
no
no
that's what the answer to the question
is
but you know you're a weak piece of [ __ ]
so not surprising and Mike Pence would
act like he's gonna be the president of
the United States I guess I don't know I
I couldn't tell if he thought there's
going to be another candidate or if he's
going to be the candidate I couldn't
really tell exactly he didn't really
give us much idea
um
you know coffee tastes really good in
this mug you see that mug
Ron DeSantis can go [ __ ] himself
speaking of a presidential candidate
maybe that's who he's talking about
maybe Mike Pence is talking about oh
Ronnie Ronnie D
I don't know
I mean Ron DeSantis also can go [ __ ]
himself and the correct answer is are
you going to vote for Ron DeSantis is
absolutely [ __ ] not
Robin says she loves the mug I'm telling
you this mug
it makes the coffee taste like liquid
gold
storm says I want that mug just go to
store.thetonymichaels.com and you can
get your Ron DeSantis
can go [ __ ] himself mug as well as you
can get in on a t-shirt if you want
store not the Tony michaels.com
you can get the Rhonda Santos can go
[ __ ] himself mug
get a hoodie it's getting cold outside I
don't know how cold it'll be in Florida
on Election Day
speaking of cold on Election Day
everyone's been ordering the zip up
hoodies and the throw over hoodies that
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty
he's going like hotcakes folks I think
it's because election season's coming up
and everyone knows they're gonna have to
stand in line to save our democracy no
matter how long it takes no matter how
cold it is if it's raining outside throw
that hood up
say it loud and proud the freedom to
oppress the rights of other people is
not Liberty
go to
stored.dtonymichaels.com
store.thetonymichaels.com to grab your
Liberty hoodie today and also again grab
your Ron DeSantis can go [ __ ] himself
mug the coffee tastes wonderful
I don't know what it does to it it just
tastes so good
you are the best audience in the world
I'm happy to have you here today
even though our co-host is out filming a
deep State PSA for the Soros Medical
Group
may or may not be about to
chlamydia I don't know I don't know I
don't know what this this um what he's
on said I really don't know what he's
filming
I really don't know but he is filming
today something I'm just making all this
[ __ ] up
um I'm trying to give Gabe some [ __ ]
maybe you should go over on Twitter and
give him some [ __ ] just go follow Gabe
on Twitter at I am Gabe Sanchez and make
sure you tag him in a post about his
deep state
film set Adventures today also don't
forget if you're on Facebook can you
hear me out there Facebook can you hear
me go over at the Tony Michaels on
Facebook follow us there I put some
videos up there we broadcast this show
on my Facebook page as well so go follow
us on Facebook download every single
episode every single weekday Monday
through Friday on Apple Spotify Google
make sure to leave a great review while
you're subscribing on your favorite
directory and downloading every single
episode we also are over on Twitch a lot
of people like the twitch chat
they swear by that's why a lot of people
go watch this thing on on Twitch is
because they like the twitch chat better
and it's a free app I don't get paid
anything we need to download the app
it's a free app try it out I don't know
maybe some people like the YouTube some
people like the face of books and some
people like the twitch thing
but we also air on Twitter so follow us
on every single platform
every single platform don't miss a
single episode here at the Tony Michaels
podcast
everyone stick around we're gonna go
through the shitless Roundup I got a lot
of video to show you today I want to
show you this Mike Pence video I want to
show you
oh my God this newscast
um where they're reporting on the uh the
the Maga the Maga Trump humping
uh College Community board member or
some [ __ ]
uh masturbating in his truck outside of
preschool the newscast on this oh my God
it's one of the best videos
and I was doing show prep this morning
to try to figure out exactly what I was
going to show you uh MJR moderator had
said something in our in our chat and
she um she brought that back up I went
and watched this newscast video and I'm
like okay show prep done that's enough
[Music]
oh this video is gold oh my God you just
can't it's it there's so many great
moments in this newscast video about
this bonehead beating off in his truck
in front of a preschool
um it's not it's on brand it's on brand
vermogloadites everyone stick around
we'll have all those clips and more when
we come back
we'll be right back right after these
messages
we'll be right back Mark
60 seconds this is the Tony Michaels
podcast
[Music]
are you numb and alone after storming
the capital have you been left out in
the cold after stealing Nancy Pelosi's
mail do you feel exposed to a government
that doesn't share your patriotic values
if any of these describe you then you're
in luck hi I'm Paul gosar and thanks to
my new product pardon blanket I've got
you covered part in blanket specifically
Works to make you feel safe and cozy
after your involvement on January 6th
and if you're one of the other members
of Congress who also helped with the
attempted coup hard and blanket will
protect you too hard and blanket is made
of a sort of soft fleece and a layer of
sheep's wool and they're a hundred
percent made in the USA don't delay and
get your pardon blanket today for just
99.99 actual pardon's not guaranteed
jumping back into it this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
welcome back to the show thanks for
sticking around to the break void the
analonic glitch to go through today
Wendy on YouTube says I want stickers
for my toolbox
and the purple hoodie we'll just go to
store.djoning michaels.com check them
out over there you can we got a lot of
different stickers over there on
store.nettonymichaels.com
we got the Dank Brandon the dark Brandon
the Ron DeSantis can go [ __ ] himself now
we got dealt mean stickers over there so
when you go check out all the stickers
and the purple hoodies
there's several hoodies over there
there's zip up ones there's pool over
ones I don't know everyone and I put
some sweaters up there too it's getting
cold outside it's getting cold so we
gotta stay warm as we're saving our
democracy because we must pile these
[ __ ] under mountains
votes mountains of votes is what we have
to do it is so important that you show
up and that not only you show up that
you get at least three votes to show up
that's what you have to do
three
and then get those three to get out of
three just encourage them and you have
to force them most people will go vote
if you ask them like hey did you vote no
no I don't know yeah you need to vote
here's why here's why it's important
they don't know how gas prices or milk
works and they're completely obsessed
with children's genitalia and what
bathrooms they're in it's in critically
important that you do not put these
people back in charge of anything at all
anything
none of it Governors local politicians
the Community College Board whatever the
hell this guy was running for
whoo
um
you cannot let it happen
you must fight for your democracy
and stay warm while you're doing it
because it's getting chilly out there
we got I don't know we're just under
three weeks away from this election
right just under three weeks
we can do this don't listen to all the
naysayers out there either I talked
about this yesterday
don't listen all the [ __ ] naysayers
out there telling you that it ain't
gonna happen and trying to give their
prediction because what they're trying
to do is they're trying to get ahead
of what could happen right because it
could be a bloodbath
on either side right they're gonna both
side [ __ ]
[ __ ] that [ __ ] you don't have to both
side stuff
look people are [ __ ] sick and tired
of trumpism they're tired of it not not
just not just [ __ ] liberals and
Democrats okay
Republicans are sick and tired of
happening [ __ ] defend these stupid
bucks
and the more we press them the more we
make them defend them that the more
exhausted they'll get
of Defending these pieces of [ __ ]
just keep at it
we have to keep yelling and screaming
and pushing and leaning into it [ __ ]
them
they're the ones who did this to their
party not us we didn't do this to their
[ __ ] party they chose this route they
chose to have the Christian nationalism
up front and center
they chose to capitulate to a to a
[ __ ] [ __ ] Grabber acting like he's
some kind of God
so that's their decision they did that
they made that bed they better sleep in
it
and we have to do that we have to do
that for him
because folks there are people out there
that voted for Trump twice
who were sick and [ __ ] tired of
hearing his name they're tired of it
they're tired of having to listen to how
he [ __ ] stole documents
how he's gonna have to probably give his
DNA in the E Gene Carol
trial
how he how he [ __ ] defrauded this the
state of New York and probably the
federal government and his tax fraud
schemes with his businesses
this state elector thing is really
heating up folks I don't know if you've
noticed but holy [ __ ] The Oath Keepers
are on trial today
and they're they're they're they're
they're reading signal chats in the open
courtroom
and saying basically Trump better enact
the Insurrection act because we're
bringing our guns and they did
they were talking about a coup plot
and that's what Mike Pence's role in the
whole goddamn thing was
to sneak in a few States fraudulent
electors
that would say they certified Trump
which was not the truth
that's all [ __ ] they're fraudulent
they're illegal
and there are people gonna go to jail
over it they've requested a federal
judge has requested more emails from
John Eastman more emails that do not
pertain to attorney privilege
and I don't know if you're aware of what
attorney and what client that they're
talking about they're talking about
Trump
I'm telling you
it's most important
to make these [ __ ] be accountable not
just in the law not just in January 6
but in your everyday conversations you
have to make these these people who
voted for Trump twice who aren't
necessarily Trump supporters I'm not
talking about the ones with the [ __ ]
flags and they're they're outspouting
queuing on [ __ ] and they're just cultist
I'm not talking about the [ __ ] the
cultist I'm talking about the people who
capitulate to those [ __ ]
who pretend like oh yeah that stuff's
all normal that q and on stuff that's
all normal
no it isn't
and they voted for his ass twice and
hated the [ __ ] what's time it's
time they have to [ __ ] make an
argument for why you're gonna vote for
people just like him
why are you gonna vote for JD Vance
who called him America's Hitler and then
is [ __ ] kissing his ass that's
Trump's words
you're gonna vote for Dr Oz who doesn't
even live in Pennsylvania
who killed hundreds of puppies in a
medical study
who couldn't find Penn State on a map
doesn't even know what grocery stores
are in Pennsylvania
really you're gonna vote for that
[ __ ] because Trump supports him
because Trump backed him you're gonna
you're going to vote for a brain dead
abortion paying abusive piece of [ __ ]
like Herschel Walker because he stands
in front of a microphone and says he's
Christian
you have to press these people you have
to make them defend themselves
because trust me when they get in that
booth
when they go to the poll and they're
marked because they're not going to do
mailing they've already oh man they've
already been man sets that's fraudulent
they're watching [ __ ] male they're
watching goddamn voting boxes they're
they're participating in in voter
intimidation out in Arizona I'm going to
show you that clip too there's another
another [ __ ] news clip of that we
talked about that several weeks ago
with with Jeff Timmer
on here
about how these [ __ ] are trying
to use voter intimidation by filming
voter mail-in ballot drop boxes
really [ __ ] stupid [ __ ]
they're out of their minds they're out
of their minds because they got this
that movie the 2000 mules which people
are going to go to prison for that
it just doesn't end with these
[ __ ] and listen that's why you
got to keep pressing these people and
I'm talking about not just the
politicians I'm talking about the people
who support these [ __ ]
and that the ones again with the [ __ ]
bumper stickers and the hats and the
flags not the cultists
I'm talking about the cultist
capitulators
the ones you're like add at q9 stuff
that's that's ridiculous but I I I'm a
conservative and I vote for bibkins
so
rather they're Nazis or not because they
got an R next year just hold those
[ __ ] accountable that
[ __ ]
your Uncle Earl
maybe it's your Uncle Ed I don't know
I don't know which one it is Earl might
be the overt coke uh cultist he's got
the hats and the flags
he's the one that's always running
around he he posts on Facebook all the
Trump 2024.
you know that kind of [ __ ] that's Earl
Ed his brother your Uncle Ed
he um
he's he's just a capitulator right
women shouldn't have rats and
Republicans don't want women to have
rights so I'm a republican I'm a
conservative I believe in lower deficits
lower taxes
so I'm a republic you met this
[ __ ] before right
how many of these [ __ ] have you
met in your life I know at least at
least 50 of them
at least 50 of them that are
capitulators not overt cultists but
capitulators and those are the ones you
have to hold accountable now what will
happen if you hold the mechanel they'll
do one or two things they're so
exhausted of having to defend this
nonsense
that they'll just not go vote for anyone
fine stay the [ __ ] home that's your
choice in this country
with your vote
fine by me or they'll go and they'll
Mark Sanity on the ballot
um
one or the other
but you gotta lean into it
I I know there's a lot of folks on here
that are in red States blue dots and red
States I I think that's a lot of the
audience that
listens to what I say because I'm a blue
dot in a red State and really I hate
that kind of terminology
because it it makes you sound like
you're something different we're not
different we just we're not [ __ ]
boneheads
it doesn't take us more than five or ten
minutes to figure out gasoline isn't
tied to a button on the president's desk
that the reason why the [ __ ] milk is
so high is because Grandpa poopy pants
made a really shitty deal with dairy
with Canada it's not [ __ ] difficult
to understand these things it's not hard
to figure out that trans People Are
People Too they're just [ __ ] people
you dummy
they're just [ __ ] people
that's it they're humans just like you
just like the migrants coming across the
border they're [ __ ] humans just like
you it doesn't take much brain power and
logic and rationale to figure that out
so we're not something different in a
red state
we just wake up and use our brains in
the morning
put two and two together and there's
more of us than you think
there's a lot of us out there
hell a lot of them are here watching
right now they're in the chat right now
I get the message so many times
I live around all these magas
my family's full of them yep mine too
mine too
but you gotta lean in to democracy and
the way that you do it is you hold these
people to the fire you hold them
accountable to their [ __ ] and if
they're gonna go vote for Maga
Republicans then make them tell you why
make them smoke it out a bit and again
I'm not talking about the cultists
they're [ __ ] lost
yeah you you're not gonna you're not at
this point three weeks before the 2022
midterm you're not gonna turn a lot of
these cultists these Maga Trump cultists
into Believers of democracy that's why
they're a cultist maybe a couple of them
but it's it's not gonna snap overnight
like that
there's long off ramps that happen for
Colts
it's a really long off-ramp
now there's things that trigger that
off-ramp but it's a really long one and
we ain't got time to stand around
[ __ ] arguing with a bunch of Cuban
honors we just don't but you know what
we can do we can take those q and honors
and we can say hey look we can
politicize the [ __ ] out of them and we
can say hey look all Republicans are
these this is what the Republican party
is going to be if you keep [ __ ] doing
this [ __ ] if you elect Dr Oz and JD
Vance and Herschel Walker Ron DeSantis
Greg Abbott Eric Schmidt Ron Johnson
Kerry Lake
Masters if you put these people in
charge of [ __ ]
you're gonna get more of this because
they're [ __ ] crazy
and they capitulate the politicians
capitulate to the cultist it's the tail
wagging the dog
so hold them hold their [ __ ] feet to
the fire make them tell you make your
Uncle Ed tell you why he's gonna go vote
for Dr Oz or if he lives in Ohio why the
[ __ ] are you gonna go vote for JD Vance
why
he's a weak piece of [ __ ] number one
and number two
what is JD Vance gonna do for Ohio
that Tim Ryan isn't saying he's already
trying to do
same with Herschel Walker Warnock is a
sitting United States Senator what in
the [ __ ] is in the word salad that
Herschel Walker when he actually talks
into a microphone
is saying that it's gonna give Georgia
anything better because he claims to be
a Christian oh [ __ ] all these Nazis
claim to be Christians all of them claim
to be Christians [ __ ] out of here with
that nonsense
I've met real Christians in my life I'm
an atheist
and I've met real Christians in my life
and not I haven't met one real Christian
that resembles any one of these [ __ ]
self-proclaimed Christians
Mike Herschel Walker or Donald Trump
Dr Oz or who the [ __ ] ever JD Vance
Blake Masters Matt Walsh [ __ ] out of
here
with your bigoted nonsense
imagine trying to stand around and let
your Uncle Ed convince you that Jesus
was a bigot
you [ __ ] [ __ ] me
literally that's
what they're saying
they're using their religion to be
bigots
and the religion is Christianity which I
don't know it has this book about this
dude named Jesus Christ that's where
Christ Christian that's where it comes
from
Jesus [ __ ]
it's really simple to [ __ ] break down
these people's mindset trust me I know
their arguments are not tied to
intellectual [ __ ] arguments and big
huge [ __ ] stacks of stats that's the
one thing that Democrats and liberals do
wrong they [ __ ] do it wrong that's
why I do it differently here
they're always wanting to throw a
[ __ ] book of stats at you in some
kind of intellectual argument why you
don't need one what what on Earth do you
need a a [ __ ] whole stack of stats
and a bunch of [ __ ] a bunch of
[ __ ] studies and a bunch of
intellectual Army Arguments for hey the
LGBT community they're [ __ ] humans
and we should treat them that way
are you what the [ __ ] else you you need
all that to make that argument
you must not believe in the argument if
you need all that to make that argument
it really is not that [ __ ] hard
it's not that hard to make arguments of
why the president doesn't have a
gasoline button on his desk
really isn't it really is not a hard
argument
for parents
to make to parents to say hey kids
should start school at three instead of
five they should do that
you I mean just just go out and talk to
even cultist parents and say kids should
start three instead of five just say
that to them
maybe with kind of a question mark you
think kids should start three and school
is three instead of five yeah that
sounds like good I can't afford daycare
anyways Jesus Christ with the way
inflation is and my wages aren't
following that inflation Jesus Christ I
can't even afford the milk because
Donald Trump made a shitty deal on Dairy
with Canada
ask ask folks do you think you should go
broke because of a medical bill
ask him that
you don't need [ __ ]
mountains of stats
you don't need a big huge intellectual
argument and a TED Talk for people to
understand that in this country the
richest [ __ ] country on Earth
that you should not go broke because of
a medical bill
it's not that difficult
it really isn't
some people got mad yesterday that I I
attacked tyt the Young Turks Unger
they got real pissed off at me
how dare you attack our side he's he's
giving both sides arguments and a really
shitty one at that he's not on our side
okay
he's not on pro-democracy's side
he's not
he tweeted something this morning that
gets him better gets him closer and I
retweeted it go look at it maybe I'll
show it to you here and the [ __ ] list
Roundup
I'm telling you folks I'm telling you
this did we do not need a bunch of
intellectual arguments
it is not it does not take a lot of
brain power to understand these things
and the more you try to get people in
America
as because their [ __ ] privilege
especially those white ones God damn do
they have some them some privilege trust
me I knows I is ones
if you if you try
to use a bunch of [ __ ] and a bunch
of intellectual arguments and [ __ ] they
gotta carry around a [ __ ] notebook
or carry around a list of links so they
can go give you the the source of your
information what [ __ ] source of
information do you need other than
decency
that that transgender people and
children and LGBT community are [ __ ]
people are humans and we shouldn't
dehumanize them what what [ __ ] Source
do you need what [ __ ] link do you
need to understand that migrants from
Venezuela trying to trying to escape a
murderous Communist Regime to come to
this country for Asylum so they can be
part of our country and contribute to
our country and be the Future Leaders of
our country
that they're humans
and their people and they have great
stories and culture to bring with them a
lot to give to our great nation
just like the immigrants and migrants
before them
that's where we're at today what [ __ ]
link do you need
you need me to provide you a link to
[ __ ] get that in your thick skull get
the [ __ ] out of here with that nonsense
that's why the left and Democrats have
always been shitty at this
and they continue this [ __ ] with tyt
and The Young Turks and this argument
Democrats can't win because the polls
and because oh you're [ __ ] people out
there believe this [ __ ] and they're
oh they're not they're really concerned
about gas prices
they're concerned about gas prices
because the left can't manage to make a
[ __ ] argument
as simple as hey there's no there's no
[ __ ] gasoline button on the
president's desk and really if you look
at [ __ ] gas prices the reason why is
because the [ __ ] greedy ass oil
companies are gouging you you dumb
[ __ ] how the [ __ ] don't you
know that corporations are blaming Biden
and [ __ ]
sticking it in without Vaseline all at
the same time how don't you know this
and until you get off your dumb ass and
blame the correct people and start
aiming your [ __ ] outrage towards the
people who are actually stealing your
[ __ ] money at the pump it won't
change
for decades we were pissed off at the
oil corporations because they were
[ __ ] us
and then Trump comes along and he he
sends out a few messages that Biden's
the one in making gas prices higher and
the entire country goes oh yes prizes
are batons false listen we have cheap
gas here
you go anywhere else around the world
it's expensive as [ __ ]
it's cheap here the reason why it feels
so goddamn high is because wages are so
[ __ ] low hey there's another one that
we don't need a shitload of [ __ ]
statistics
low wages a decent [ __ ] wage
you don't need a [ __ ] stack of
statistics and a big intellectual
argument and a TED talk to understand
that people just want to get paid what
they're worth
and to have a decent [ __ ] wage so
they don't have to have three goddamn
jobs
listen inflation is good
but it's only it's only good for the
middle and lower class when their wages
increase
the demand is high folks this [ __ ]
[ __ ] that the economy's bad is all
nonsense it's horseshit corporations are
gouging you with fake ass inflation
because you're spending you're you're
paying the money and keep doing it don't
stop don't stop buying [ __ ]
because you'll depress the economy it
will I don't know recess which is the
opposite of inflate
but what you should do in the meantime
is out there making arguments that
people should have a decent [ __ ] wage
don't be talking about minimum wage or
any kind of scary Universal income and
all that scary ass [ __ ] that's terrifies
American privileged people white folks
because when you start making arguments
that sound like you're going to take
away something from someone that's when
they really get there oh hey be a
[ __ ] Universal what
it's a bad word don't use it
we don't need the word Universal in
anything
absolutely nothing to make an argument
and if you really believe that you have
to use the word Universal in pre-k or
health care or college or income if you
think you need to use that [ __ ] word
in any of your arguments you're not
making good arguments you're just not
a good argument isn't something that
that is backed by 200 Pages worth of
research a good argument is something
that you can spout off in one
[ __ ] sentence and it makes
sense
that's a good [ __ ] argument
that's a good argument
and if we don't start making those
arguments and we don't start challenging
these people
to these and holding their feet to the
fire for the stupid [ __ ] I mean God damn
with with gas prices you start people
start getting into an argument again
about gas prices and some [ __ ]
will bring up the word Keystone
right
they'll bring up the word Keystone
and then you gotta go into a whole
[ __ ] Ding and a Diet tribe and
all this [ __ ] and blah blah blah just
say this
say Do you believe that oral oil
companies those big corporations
the ones that have massive profits are
trying to [ __ ] you at the pump like they
try to [ __ ] everyone everywhere the big
business the billionaires the rich
they're gonna be like hell yeah
someone mentioned Katie Porter made an
argument she did a great job the other
day at this with one little chart she
didn't need a whole book of stats she
just and really honestly you couldn't
even see the [ __ ] numbers on it and
you don't need to see the [ __ ]
numbers on it and they give numbers but
you don't need the numbers
you don't need [ __ ] numbers for
people understand this people understand
that corporations are [ __ ] greedy
they get it they know what how
capitalism Works hell they they part of
it day's greedy too
but until we can get boneheads to
[ __ ] blame the correct people and aim
their outrage towards the correct
[ __ ] which is the which is
corporations
you're not you're not gonna it doesn't
matter what argument you [ __ ] make
it doesn't matter what kind of [ __ ]
charts you show them or or statistics
you pile on them or what links you give
them
if you are sitting here and believing
that the reason why inflation sucks
right now isn't because of [ __ ]
corporations
you're not doing this whole capitalism
thing correctly
like literally if you are sitting here
not knowing that corporations are the
ones who were causing The Strife in
inflation
you're not you're not doing the
capitalism thing correctly
you literally are not a camper and some
people aren't again some people are
socialists
because here's what corporations are
doing not only are they gouging you
at the pump and and when you're checking
out at the register
they're gouging you at your wages
now wages are higher than they were and
that's why we still have a certain
amount of demand
because people are making more money
because they have to the employers have
to pay them have you seen all the help
wanted signs look when there's Help
Wanted signs everywhere and
unemployment's down at three and a half
percent that that's like virtually we we
need more people to work that's why we I
don't know uh do immigration
we bring more people here to contribute
their labor literally when you go take a
job and they pay you a certain amount of
money per hour per week per month per
year you're trading your labor for money
that's capitalism you're trading it just
like when you go in and you give money
for a loaf of bread same [ __ ]
thing it's the same thing now there's
different regulations and laws
and different taxes on that but it's the
same goddamn thing
there is no difference in you going in
and spending x amount of Dollar on a
loaf of bread and then someone hiring
you for x amount of dollars per hour per
month per week per year whatever the
[ __ ] agreement is
maybe it's a commission I don't know
whatever you agree to your to your your
[ __ ] work contract
you're trading your labor or your
service whatever it is
and sometimes sometimes you're the
business owner
and that's your service see that's the
other [ __ ] thing that people get
twisted that oh business owners business
owners are are the job creators no
they're not business owners are not job
creators
business owners just don't trade their
labor for money
they use their business to trade goods
and services
through their business and a lot of
times they hire labor to make those
products
and provide those services
but it's the demand that creates the
jobs why do you think there's so many
[ __ ] help wanted signs
again I don't need have I gave you one
[ __ ] statistic this entire time
no because you don't need to you do not
need to make
big stacks of links and send someone a
link for them to understand what
capitalism is we've all this is entire
country is built on it
the whole [ __ ] culture and
institution is built on capitalism
that's why this idea that you're going
to undo capitalism is [ __ ] dumb
literally that's why fascism is leaking
in
what do you think fascism is other than
authoritarian capitalism
it's what it is
let's do this
I gotta get to the ah man that is a big
rant first rant second rant we're at an
hour already we got to do the [ __ ] list
Roundup I got to show you this video of
Mike Pence
and then we got to get to some of these
other videos crazy ass videos and you
gotta see you gotta show your Uncle Ed
and say hey this is the people you want
to support these crazy bucks so let's do
this let's get to the [ __ ] let's round
let's surf the Tweety tweets the trendy
Trends start the countdown
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
but we round up all the Tweety tweets
and the trendy Trends did you see this
video
of Mike Pence trying to answer the
question
would he vote for Trump again there's
only one right answer here but let's
watch what Mike Pence's answer is it's
only it's only less than 30 seconds long
make sure I got my volume levels going
here there we go all right let's listen
to Mike Pence's answer to the question
would you vote for Trump
's list in the history Department Mr
Pence if Donald Trump is the Republican
nominee for president in 2024 will you
vote for him
[Applause]
okay again the correct answer to this
and the only well not the only but the
the the immediate correct answer this is
no the next one is absolutely [ __ ]
not
well let's listen to what former vice
president who Trump and his
band of insurrectionist traitors wanted
to hang him let's see what he has to say
well there might be somebody else I'd
prefer more
so yes but yes he would vote for him if
he's the only one he prefers himself
more I think that's what he's saying
here right
now what you guys think
I take that he's talking about himself
he says he's gonna [ __ ]
he's gonna [ __ ] run
that's right I think that's what he's
saying but he's also saying if there
wasn't anyone else
it wasn't anyone else well then
I would have to vote for him because
there's no one else on the ballot so
yeah I would vote for him
because Mike Pence you weak piece of
[ __ ] the answer is no every time doesn't
matter who ask it where the [ __ ] you
asking at it doesn't matter the context
in which you ask it in this is a black
and white kind of situation here would
you vote for Donald Trump the answer is
no the next obvious answer again is
absolutely [ __ ] not
I don't understand why this is difficult
for a guy who wanted
um who encouraged his supporters to hang
him I don't know
I don't know why it's so hard I have no
idea everyone's kind of agreeing with me
here in the chat but yeah they I yeah
Laura even says here on YouTube she says
I think Pence is hinting right
yeah he's doing this thing in this
answer again when he should be not a
coward and just say no he's you know
he's hinting it maybe he'll he'll run
and Faye says it here Pence is a coward
of course he is he of course he is
here's a here's another here's maybe the
third uh correct answer to this question
Mojo has it here a hard no
that would be a stiff hard no absolutely
[ __ ] not thank you very much not
voting for Donald Trump okay let's move
on to um another uh video here let's see
oh oh
um here's here's um I want to talk about
this
this is uh we we featured this a couple
weeks ago and we have Jeffrey tamaron to
talk about it remember there was a video
out and we kind of went viral we we went
over it
where they were saying they were gonna
uh use election intimidation tactics
where they were going to try to you know
watch people and take pictures of the
license plates all kinds of crazy ass
[ __ ] that there was going to be an app
that you put all this data on so they
could track these people I mean it's
voter intimidation because what they're
trying to do is intimidate people and
not voting and the particular type of
voting that they're talking about is
mail-in ballots or absentee ballots in
some states it depends on the state
you're in of what it's called because in
some states like Missouri you actually
have to have an absentee reason you have
to have a reason why you can't go to the
polls to vote to get a mail-in ballot
so it's called an absentee ballot in
some states it's just simply a mail-in
ballot because you don't need an excuse
you can just request one in some states
they send them I guess they they just
they [ __ ] send you your bag who to
thunk what an idea just send to your
ballot that way you can vote
I mean they print them anyways just send
them to you you fill it out you send it
back whatever and yesterday I went on a
tirade about how because Marco Rubio
said that these voting mail-in ballot
voting
um drop boxes
are you know some people going to throw
bombs in them or some [ __ ] again the
only people that are really truly
concerned about these things as a threat
to our democracy are [ __ ] moglodytes
the domestic terrorists and and this
apparently is one now let me
pull the banner down here because I want
you to see again this is on uh War Room
the trader TV News Network oh by the way
Steve Bannon is apparently going to go
to jail tomorrow did you guys know that
Friday is when Steve Bannon is going to
be sentenced to jail
um the prosecutor is asking for six
months so we'll see maybe he won't be on
his Trader TV I'm sure he'll have a
feeling like hoof foot green okay so
this is uh again on Steve bannon's war
room but if you see her name is Melanie
Jenkins and she's with clean elections
USA
remember that that is important for
another video I'm going to show you she
is with clean elections USA
I but it's just they have the shittiest
names that they pick out
the shittiest names that they pick out
right
whoosh when when they're talking about
cleansing and [ __ ] God damn you people
really do lean into the Nazi don't you
okay so this lady here she's gonna tell
us
how she's going to intimidate people
from
putting their ballot into a secure
a secure more secure Dropbox than like a
mailbox let's listen people are getting
the word they are showing up our people
are showing up and gathering around
boxes and uh shutting this stuff down
what these mules don't understand is
just because
did she say mules
she mean like donkeys oh wait this has
to do with that [ __ ] that movie 2000
mules that's why this is all this
delusions gaming Brim
is this nonsense
that that somehow illegally people are
placing their ballots their legal
balance in a legal Dropbox
literally Republicans the same
[ __ ] fascist that are standing
around these boxes trying to intimidate
people not to put their ballots in them
are the same [ __ ] who are
trying to take the boxes away and
frankly it's the same party who invented
this idea that's right the Republicans
invented the absentee mail-in ballot
idea
and the reason why is because they're
voting block
in the past was a lot of people who
couldn't get out to vote on voting day
because they're elderly
they have to stay at home they can't get
out to go vote so they would have
absentee answer that [ __ ] thing comes
from the other voting block that they
relied on with absentee ballots was
military
huge block of Voters
literally
a bunch of the military uses mail-in and
absentee ballots
some of them probably even drop them in
drop boxes
that this lady is saying are I don't
know some sort of conspiracy to steal
elections by dropping your legal ballot
into a secure box it's really [ __ ]
dumb [ __ ]
but she's calling them mules
imagine imagine the party that you were
voting for all these years
and you voted and you're part of their
big voting block using absentee and
mail-in ballots now to think that you're
a traitor
if you vote legally in your state
through mail-in or absentee ballot
hmm
maybe want to mention that to your Uncle
Ed let's listen to what what else this
traitor has to say because you know I
put a fuzzy still shot up on true social
that doesn't look like anything we're
Geotech okay
you posting anything on true social
ah this [ __ ] idiot if you're posting
anything on true social as if this is
some sort of [ __ ]
um
fact-finding Mission what they're doing
is they're taking video and and they're
taking still shots of people who go to
these boxes and drop their ballots
it's legal to do that that is a thing
you have that right and well in some
states you don't because they're taking
them away
right some states you don't have it
anymore because they don't have them I I
believe in Houston
in the city of Houston there's like one
[ __ ] Dropbox
secure Dropbox and the reason why people
want to drop their ballot in a secure
Dropbox and they're willing to go to a
secure Dropbox is because the other box
that you put it in isn't secure it's
called a mailbox
because it's a male in ballot that's
the entire [ __ ] concept
how to what is this are these people
gonna stand outside people's homes and
watch them put their ballot in the mail
box
people are [ __ ] boneheads this is
voter intimidation
I would imagine these people are edging
in such a gray area and really in
election law especially federal election
law you do not want to live in a gray
area you don't
and the reason why is because it's easy
to prosecute in those gray areas you see
it with Ron DeSantis trying to [ __ ]
bang up a bunch of people down in
Florida for voter fraud when they didn't
commit voter fraud
there was no malice intent
Jesus Christ they locked up a woman in
Texas for like six years because she
thought she could vote and she couldn't
so and these people should be very
careful when it comes to elections and
intimidation because it's borderline it
is and it's a
it's intimidation let's finish
how she's going to intimidate voters
tracking them we've got cameras on the
back sides of them you know people are
freaking out because they say this
picture doesn't prove anything that's
okay we have the sauce we're just
showing you that we're out there and
people are coming and joining us and
it's great camaraderie uh going on in
Michigan we're about to go viral all
over the state I've got people all lined
up getting ready to March out there
around your boxes so beyond notice
um tutor Dixon mattapurno are here to
help
oh you're viral all right Melanie you're
a [ __ ] virus Jesus Christ these
[ __ ] people okay now let me go to
this another video it's a newscast
um this is in Arizona
um and and this is their great
and this is Maricopa County right
this is the election Headquarters in
Maricopa County if you're unaware uh of
the news of Maricopa County do you
remember in 2020
when Trump came out and said stop
counting the vote stop the Steal You
Remember on that stop counting on that
[ __ ] this is where all these people
showed up at the office at the counting
office the headquarters where they were
counting that night
and they were they were [ __ ] almost
rioting outside the Maricopa County
headquarters that's where this is at
that's where this is at that's why you
see the big [ __ ] fences and [ __ ] up
because they had to put up big [ __ ]
fences to to Corral these crazy Cuban
honors from trying to hurt election
volunteers and election officials that
are doing their job but here here is
their big movement okay this is their
big movement watch how many people are
watching this box you see back here
there's a tripod and it looks like
um this is like a holder I've got a few
of them here I don't have one handy to
show you
um it holds a cell phone right and it's
it's just you know you can put a like a
like a camera on like a camcorder or
something on this tripod but this game's
probably using his iPhone or some [ __ ]
right which even worse like literally it
he's he's
taking digital evidence on his cell
phone of all the crimes that he's
possibly committing when he's committing
election intimidation and voter
intimidation but um with this tripod
back here but you see it's abc15 is the
microphone here that's interviewing them
I believe let me see let me see what her
name is uh Nicole Nicole Grigg you know
I'm gonna give her credit here on this
um
Nicole Grigg of ABC 15 I believe is the
uh yeah ABC 15. she's a reporter with
ABC 15. she decided to go ask these
band of idiots what the [ __ ] they're
doing taking pictures of people dropping
their mail and balance into the secure
dropbox at the Maricopa County
headquarters this is literally outside
the headquarters
the election headquarters where they
count the [ __ ] ballots this isn't
like in some [ __ ] weird neighborhood
somewhere where there's you know it's in
a dark alley and the boxes down a dark
alley with a bunch of you know George
Soros deep State cabal around it or
something I don't know it's at the
headquarters the [ __ ] headquarters of
the county where they count the votes
and people just want to make sure their
vote gets counted it's crucial in our
democracy right now because of [ __ ]
like this let's listen
we're just out here watching boxes
and before I make any kind of statement
or anything I'd like to yeah get in the
center getting some vitamin D
ude so you're getting vitamin D or
you're watching the Dropbox
so you can tell this [ __ ] idiot's
been coached right he's been coached
what to say
and the first mistake he makes with this
great reporter who keeps questioning
them and you'll see she just keeps
questioning him
is the first thing he does is he says
what they're doing which is watching
boxes
and then he's like whoa well you know
what before I make a statement which I
already made a statement I know I
already made one but before I make a
statement I need to make a phone call oh
by the way I just remembered I don't
need to make that phone call anymore
because what I'm supposed to say is that
I'm just enjoying the Sun and I just
happen to have this tripod in camera
literally you can tell this is coached
and you can tell these boneheads have no
idea why they're there and what they're
actually doing and possible crimes that
they may be committing
they may it depends on what they do with
the information that they're Gathering
and who they give it to and their
motives behind it you could stand and
film anything you want from a public
sidewalk right we know that you can
stand on a public sidewalk and you can
film something right now you can't go on
private property and do that necessarily
I mean unless you got a permit or
something
but generally speaking in public you can
be filming anything you want really I
mean you're on a public sidewalk you can
have your camera on
right
that's not inherently illegal now there
are
there are situations where there's
motives
and there's intent and if it's criminal
then it's illegal but let's let's listen
to who this guy's gonna call listen
Maybe Ghostbusters
uh has anyone responded to you driving
through has been
has it um before I say anymore I need to
call somebody okay
um who are you gonna call me
okay Ghostbusters
Who you gonna call ghost
are you [ __ ] kidding me oh man you
just can't make this [ __ ] up it's all
it's better than satire
you you literally could not could not
make this [ __ ] up this guy just said
he's watching boxes and then he said hey
hey I think um
I think I'm getting sun and I need to
call someone and then she asks who are
you gonna call
I love I love Griggs here and great
reporters yeah look at her smiling you
can tell she's smiling and you don't
even have to see the front of her face
Who you gonna call
okay let's let's see if he's gonna say
who he's gonna call what organization
are you with
new elections USA whoa whoa whoa did you
hear that he's with clean elections USA
where do we know that from hmm
where do we know that from clean
elections USA it's almost like we just
watched a video with someone on Steve
bannon's Trader TV News Network so here
is here is Steve bannon's chart Army
right here outside Maricopa County
taking pictures using using their
ability to take pictures
as voter intimidation because people may
have their their information put out on
the internet that they [ __ ] used
their constitutional right to drop a
ballot in a secure box at the
headquarters of Maricopa County
elections
and Steve Bannon is behind the whole
[ __ ] thing
how [ __ ] surprised am I not at all
anyone down there
actually actually I'd like to talk to
them before I talk to you
okay so he says I'm not allowed have you
talked to anyone down there he says no
I'm not allowed to talk to anybody and
then he says I would really like to talk
to them before I talk to you so which is
it hero
which is it are can you talk to him can
you not talk to him can you not talk to
her because she doesn't told her what
this is [ __ ] stupid
again
here's here's the good news folks they
literally are the shart Army they are
some dumb [ __ ]
they these people are so [ __ ] deluded
that they can't even manage to take
coaching
that is given to them
and use that coaching to answer simple
questions from a reporter with the
microphone
I'm telling you
I know it seems like an uphill battle
but these are nincompoop Nazis
these are not the Nazis of the 30s and
40s these are nincompoops and the reason
why they're nincompoop Nazis
is because they have they have to use
buffoonery
and ridiculous conspiracy theories that
are easily debunked in this day and age
in the 1930s and 1940s conspiracy
theories and misinformation was not
easily debunked
today it is it's really easy to
challenge them she's doing a wonderful
job here I know it feels like the
reporter is really not doing much but
you don't have to do much when this
guy's such a [ __ ] idiot let's
continue okay
what's your name uh
no oh look look there's so many of these
people taking pictures
it's almost like
Facebook probably a q Anon group on
Facebook probably recruited a husband
and a wife here
hmm
and and they decided they were able to
convince these dumb [ __ ] to
possibly go
and participate in voter intimidation
in the name of trump
and clean elections Q Anon USA whatever
this thing is but listen to what this
late this lady she does the coaching
better than the other guy the other guy
he did not he did
he didn't he didn't quite get the
coaching down right he didn't get the
script down but she's got it watch this
she's got the script
he was having a discussion with anybody
about anything I'm just here there you
go see that's what he was supposed to
say
that's what he was supposed to say now
Charlie
um from Facebook they are doxing they
are doxing
um this is the definition of doxing
because people dropping their ballot in
a in a male or excuse me a ballot drop
box a secure dropbox at a headquarters
is not them giving public information
they're lit literally they're doing the
opposite they're taking their ballot
that they requested or received in the
mail and they're going and making sure
it's in a secure box
and really honestly all mailboxes are
secure and they're secured by federal
law but the one that's sitting on the
premises here at the headquarters is
secured by bolting it to the [ __ ]
ground having a lock on the son of a
[ __ ] and probably having lights and
cameras on the on the bastard that's how
it's secure and these people are doxing
by spreading their information again it
doesn't you you are allowed to film and
take pictures from a public sidewalk
like this
but your intent
and your motive if Criminal
is it's criminal dummy okay let's let
but here's her coach she goes on to be
coached here just watch and checking in
the vitamin D taking in vitamin DC yep
it looks like the vitamin D flying into
my body the vitamin vitamin D vitamin D
flying into your body okay see that see
she's well coached this is why women are
so much better than men this is a
perfect example a perfect example why
Women are Smarter better they they will
they just are better than this woman
absolutely took her coaching to heart
and understood it probably wrote it down
put it to memory not that far and then
boom she got it the first try dude
couldn't [ __ ] figure it out
dude couldn't figure it out
now This Woman's crazy
This Woman's crazy she's absolutely
deluded and delusional
but this just shows you uh men versus
women
there's no [ __ ] competition okay
let's continue
so are you recording the the drop boxes
then I'm really not able to comment no
comment thank you
thank you I'm not able to come see she's
well well coached
I'm not able to comment yep that's
you're good why not
damn see
okay see we got the camera see that's
perfect see she did such a good job if
you're gonna commit crime you probably
should not not admit to it in front of a
camera into a microphone
you probably should just say no comment
no comment no comment no comment it's
probably what you should do you
shouldn't you shouldn't be like yeah
we're out here taking pictures of the
boxes and we're gonna post it on the
Internet with with this group called
clean Q Anon elections USA and uh
they're gonna dox a bunch of people it's
probably crime and I'm part of it and
I'm gonna say that into a microphone
with a camera pointed at me foreign
when you do crime or potential crime you
really you really shouldn't say it
in into a microphone holy [ __ ]
dumb [ __ ] okay uh let's see
I want to do the John Oliver Matt Walsh
thing Matt Walsh responded to John
Oliver but I can't play the John Oliver
part and the reason why is because
YouTube will [ __ ] will [ __ ] with my
uh they'll they'll do a copyright uh HBO
will do a copyright on it but we I'll
show you the Matt Walsh part
um if you want to see the uh John Oliver
video it's really good it actually it's
it's real you just go to his Twitter
account
um Last Week Tonight or John Oliver you
can find it it's about the little little
girl who is a transgender girl and uh
Matt Walsh is a [ __ ] bigot and
absolutely tries to dehumanize this
little girl take away our entire
Humanity
and he does it in I don't know two
minutes less than two minutes this
[ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
like I said I tell you what
if I'm ever within a spinning distance
of this [ __ ] I'm not saying I
would I'm just saying if I'm that close
I I it's probably not going to go well
for Welsh if you notice here if you
notice here
um Matt Walsh is little
uh room behind him you know I got a
bunch of [ __ ] behind me too you know it
happens when you when you sit in front
of a microphone and talk he's got a
banjo back there that's not surprising
he's got a banjo but if you look at his
shelf there and he's got a trophy uh
looks like a basketball trophy I don't
know he's really proud of that but he's
got his little book there called what is
the woman he literally does not know
what a woman is he doesn't know because
he wrote a book asking the question
like the whole [ __ ] book he made a
movie what what's a woman he went around
the country trying to figure out what a
woman is
and this piece of [ __ ] is piece of [ __ ]
dehumanizes this little girl
and I tell you what I'll tell you what
um
you know there's lgbtq adults out there
um and we need to be allies to them but
let me tell you something
a lot of those adults could pick apart
and absolutely trash dunk Matt Walsh
into the trash just on their own
we need to be their allies but we don't
have to be their Hammer but when Matt
Walsh
goes after a little child here
this is one of the most disgusting
despicable things I have ever seen in my
[ __ ] life
when John Oliver does a piece showing
people the humanity of that little girl
regardless of what you what Matt Walsh
wants her to have in her pants or not
which is really [ __ ] weird it's
really weird because he does focus on
what genitalia this little girl has I
mean it is [ __ ] creepy ass [ __ ] he
this dude has some problems real [ __ ]
problems
and it's a [ __ ] sickness that these
[ __ ] Michael that I tab
they can't stop thinking about it it's
weird and it's what caused that [ __ ]
crazy kook down in Arizona to be
masturbating at a preschool probably
Jesus Christ again I'm not against
masturbate do it in your house man
do it in your house jeez [ __ ] in private
but here's Matt Walsh absolutely
dehumanizing children and they were here
I want to say this real quick too before
I show this clip the reason why this
pisses Matt Walsh off the most
that this that this little girl is a
transgender girl is because he Matt
Walsh would be so confused when he would
try to marry her when she's 14.
and he would think oh my God this must
make me gay because I want to marry a a
14 year old transgender girl literally
this is why he's doing this is because
of his own [ __ ] dysfunction
it has nothing to do with the little
[ __ ] girl nothing not a goddamn thing
it has to do with his dysfunction
and something's not right let's listen
agreed John I mean it is brutal and hard
to watch that is a very young boy who
has been convinced by his parents that
he is a girl
not only that but he is being paraded
around on camera and used as a political
prop he has been made not only trans but
into a trans mascot
Okay [ __ ] the reason why these people
have to parade around on camera is
because you keep saying they're not what
they are you piece of [ __ ] [ __ ]
they're only defending their Humanity
that's all they're doing Matt Walsh you
piece of [ __ ] garbage they're having
to defend their Humanity because you are
a [ __ ] bigot and people like you are
putting them in danger because you're
dehumanizing them you piece of trash
this this [ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
dehumanizing This Little Child
and and the reason why again the reason
why this this little girl is on camera
telling her story her human story
is because of people like you and you're
obsessed obsessed with their genitalia
you're obsessed with it Matt
it's a sickness you're [ __ ] sick dude
you you [ __ ] pedo piece of [ __ ] stop
stop concerning yourself with children's
genitalia stop it stop thinking about
what bathrooms people are going in what
what [ __ ] genitalia the person in the
stall next to you has stop you sick
[ __ ]
it's crazy [ __ ]
it's crazy [ __ ] that we even have to
[ __ ] have this conversation honestly
it's really [ __ ] dumb
that we I have to sit here and yell and
scream at this [ __ ] clip of this [ __ ]
box dehumanizing a little girl a child
because he Matt Walsh doesn't like her
genitalia and he can't stop thinking
about it and the only reason why this
little girl and her family has to go
defend their Humanity on camera and show
the world that they are [ __ ] humans
it's because of pieces of [ __ ] like this
who threaten their Humanity you [ __ ]
Nazi
very dark indeed
now how do I know that the boy is not a
girl well because the girl is a human
female child and that boy is a human
child but is not female he is male he is
a boy he means he means she has a dick
and he can't stop thinking about it
he's obsessed with it why Matt are you
so obsessed with their genitalia why why
are you so focused on children's
genitalia it is [ __ ] weird ass [ __ ]
they're even going so far to say
children are pretending to be cats and
dogs and [ __ ] about litter box all kinds
of just untrue [ __ ] to dehumanize
children
he's supposed to be a [ __ ] Christian
give me a [ __ ] break
not even close
you
trash bag boy if you have some other
alternative definition for the world
girl I'd love to hear it in fact nothing
you say on this subject John no argument
you present no talking point you put
forward has any meaning or any value or
any significance at all if you cannot or
will not Define the words you're using
okay Matt you want me to find it for you
you [ __ ] idiot
girl woman lady whatever you want to say
whatever the f whatever word you want to
use for the gender of a female let me
tell you what it is are you listening
Maddie are you [ __ ] listening get
your headphones on buddy I'm about to
tell you the definition of the word a
woman
it is a gender that people identify as
got it
you need to write it down [ __ ] it is
a gender that people identify as
you [ __ ] bonehead
now here's something else I know about
that boy aside from the fact that he is
one
the other thing I know John is that is
that being a child and being confused
and being raised in an environment which
intentionally Fosters confusion
means that he has no real concept of
what a girl is that means that sounds
like Matt Walsh is projecting here at
this point
when he's talking about how he he knows
he knows for sure
the experience of this child
he knows his thoughts inside his heads
because he seems like he has experience
of someone damaging him when he was a
child
hmm
maybe Matt Walsh wanted to be a girl and
someone forced him to be a boy I don't
know I have no idea couldn't prove it
couldn't tell you what it is or what it
isn't but he really seems obsessed with
this stuff
most people are not running around
concerning themselves
with little children
but wanting to live who they are you
[ __ ] idiot
that's most people are not like that
they're not but when he says I am a girl
the statement doesn't mean anything at
besties it does to her
how in the again he's dehumanizing this
little girl again he can't stop
he can't help himself but dehumanize and
strip away
a human's dignity even a little child
because he's obsessed with her genitalia
not her she's not obsessed with it
frankly her being a girl has nothing to
do with her genitalia not a goddamn
thing
but Matt Walsh
can't stop focusing on it he's trying to
express his affinity for or interest in
some of the things that he Associates
with girls the color pink long-haired
dolls whatever none of that
oh my God this is so stupid to think
just this dumb [ __ ] believes
that colors and the types of toys
defines a girl you are such a stupid
[ __ ]
for hundreds of years
when when when little children boys were
drawn or taken photographs of when they
were little they have dresses on a mat
they have dresses and it ain't because
they thought they were little girls had
nothing to do with that
dress is pretty pretty for pictures
pretty for paintings
this idea somehow that [ __ ] a color
defines a woman and a and a type of toy
you are such a stupid [ __ ]
that you think that a boy can't play
with a goddamn Barbie and grow up to
kick your [ __ ] ass
this is dumb stupid [ __ ] and this is
clearly damage that has been done to
Matt Walsh when he was a young little
child
that's why this is happening whoosh dude
you need to seek some [ __ ] help and
quick Matt
okay um I gotta move on here we're uh
we're about 20 minutes I want to go to
um
now there's some other crazies that I
want to get to Laura Logan's been
trending whoosh I mean it's some crazy
ass [ __ ] the problem is people are
listening to it because
she's on [ __ ] Newsmax and there's a
lot of people listening to this garbage
and it's crazy [ __ ] but the first thing
I want to do is go to Oklahoma here and
the governor's debate last night or I
think it was last night was it in
channel nine I think
um in this debate for uh Governor uh
Governor [ __ ]
um he he doesn't understand how
statistics work he doesn't understand
how numbers work he thinks because
there's not as many people in Oklahoma
as there is in big cities he doesn't
understand that the crime the crime rate
can be higher in his State even though
there's less people it's a thing that
can happen a little lesson
so let's talk about the facts the fact
is
the rates of violent crime are higher in
Oklahoma under your watch than in New
York you notice he gets defensive really
quick before she even finishes and the
reason why is because he knows this
he knows this he's been told this
is not hard to understand
one one reason why there's more [ __ ]
violence
in a state like Oklahoma than a blue
State Democrat state
is because there's more heavy access to
firearms
what do you think a lot of violent crime
comes from
[ __ ] firearms and and the
criminalization of drugs
hmm
hmm let's listen in California that's a
fact
well we'll have that fact check by the
frontier oh my God now the moderator
here of course is a [ __ ] right-wing
uh right right-wing talker uh obviously
and they're nothing more than that if
they didn't have this [ __ ] fact at
hand when they were gonna they knew they
were going to talk about crime they knew
they were going to talk about crime the
moderators should have had the [ __ ]
crime rates and could have said right in
the moment yes that is true this is true
Oklahoma has a higher rate of crime per
capita than places like New York City or
California it was not it's not hard to
gather up these things right
it's not hard and again you don't need
to [ __ ] show a bunch of links in a
pile full of Statistics to say you're
[ __ ] wrong that's [ __ ]
per capita Oklahoma has a higher crime
rate it's not hard and she really should
have said that per capita and that would
that would that would have been much
more effective or you know it is a
smaller place but there's more crime
here there's more people there it has a
lower crime rate but because they have
more people they have more crimes total
but per person there's more crime here
in Oklahoma but listen to what this is
the thing that I want to show you here
the the the
logic and this is again this goes back
to what I was ranting about and and then
B Block when we came back from the break
about arguments being made
listen to what he says here
to get and he does he he does a great
job I'm not going to Discount him here
he does exactly what he should do in
this moment
to save his to save his ass in this
debate because this moment he could have
crashed and burned here
but he didn't and what I mean by that is
he didn't with the people who were gonna
go vote for him
now if he to play games here and done
all kinds of nonsense
with and and and and tried to play the
game with her and the moderator play the
game with the actual facts
he would he would have crashed and
[ __ ] burned but he didn't he does not
play with facts here he actually plays
with fiction watch how he does it you're
a superintendent it's also a fact that
matters do you believe we have higher
crime than New York or California that's
what she just said
Oklahoma do you believe
Oklahoma
do you believe
this is what they're pre-programmed to
do buddy
this is what their pre-programmed to do
is do this [ __ ] that he just did and he
did it masterly here
regardless if you like it or not because
he's a republican piece of scum
but he did it masterfully here
because he says Oklahoma do you believe
because he's saying I don't care what
the facts are I don't care what the
facts are because she just said the
facts are and he's like I don't give a
[ __ ] what the facts are we don't deal in
facts here in Oklahoma we deal in
feelings
that's what we do
and we believe that our feelings are
correct even if they're factually wrong
they're real
so
this is what I'm talking about
when I'm saying
if you want to appeal to a mass voting
block
you can't bog them down with all kinds
of intellectual arguments you can't you
can't make them have to consume 30 45
minutes
worth of statistics and a TED Talk
you can't
what you got to do is do it in one
sentence watch what he does I'll play it
again as she says this watch this we'll
have that fact check by the frontier
superintendent it's also a fact that
medicines do you believe we have higher
crime than New York or California that's
what she just said
in a couple sentences he did he
absolutely destroys her here
now again she's right and she would make
a hell of a better Governor than he
would
just by her experience alone because
she's a woman
she has to work twice as hard to stand
on that stage than he does
so she she automatically just just in
that she's a woman and he's a man
has to work twice as hard to get on that
stage so she is a harder worker than he
is I mean you can tell that just by the
way this goofball looks
but he absolutely destroyed her argument
here
maybe she should have started out with I
know Oklahomans believe
that California New York
have higher crime rates but that's not
the truth and it doesn't matter what you
believe the truth doesn't care what you
believe the truth is the truth and the
truth is per capita we have a higher
crime rate underneath this scumbag
right you see how that works
I didn't say any statistics
it's why we it's why we have to give
better arguments we CA we got to stop
trying to appeal to people's intellect I
know that sounds backwards
but it's true
people don't want to use massive amounts
of brain power on politics they don't
they really do want to be told just like
he did here hey do you believe this come
on that can't do you do you really
believe Joe Baden was able to convince
81 million people to vote for him
do you believe it because if you believe
then it must be give me a [ __ ] break
give me a [ __ ] break so there's your
Oklahoma governor's race now again I
think she is a a formidable opponent
here uh she's super smart
um everything I've noticed she's
actually working her way up in the polls
here but I believe that moment in the
debate
um is likely to make sure that not not
to sink her campaign it won't sink her
you know just make sure he he stays he
just gave enough people enough reasons
to still go vote for him you got it just
enough reasons to go vote for him
um let's see oh we got 13 minutes left
here
and I want to play some Laura Logan clip
and I also want to play um
um Howard Stern's take on Kanye I think
that's pretty important to get his take
on that bloom
let me see what else we have here
oh I can't
I can't not do this uh this one here
this is the um
let's go to this this is a three minute
view I gotta do this this is the GOP
candidate who got arrested for whacking
off in his pickup truck
um this is the news report
um this is in channel 3 news and
wherever the [ __ ] I think this is
Arizona and this Arizona let me see
double check here I think this is
Arizona where this guy was jacking off
in his pickup truck pretty sure I'm
pretty sure yeah
it's Arizona
and this guy is running for uh the
College Board
that College Board of course you're
going to see that in the Clippers let's
let's um let's play this clip and then
the reporter who posed this is uh
Brianna Whitney so let's uh let's listen
to the news three
take now this is hilarious
this is hilarious listen our Brianna
Whitney is here now with the details of
this arrest and the implications Brianna
for the election yeah Derek there's a
lot of factors to all of this for one
thing early ballots have already gone
out with Randy Kaufman's name on them
but until he formally withdraws with the
county recorder's office he could still
win even with a public sexual indecency
charge
so what she's saying is here is this
guy's name's on the ballot they only
they already printed these [ __ ]
you can't go back and reprint them
there's a deadline you make that
deadline you print the names and there
was several years ago and there was a
governor by the name of Mel Carnahan
here in Missouri
um he was running for Senate uh against
John Ashcroft who actually ended up
being the attorney general for George W
bush and for Senate for a senate seat
here in Missouri
it's a few uh weeks before the election
Mel Carnahan was in a plane crash and he
and he died and killed him uh him and
several others one of them being his son
and Mel carnahan's name appeared on the
ballot because they couldn't take it off
because it was already printed
so the dead guy beat a republican here
in Missouri That's How Far We've Come
folks
That's How Far We've Come
is the dead guy beat and the Republican
in Missouri and we've come a long ways
from that so what she's saying here
though is you can't take someone's name
off the ballot if they've already been
printed because I don't know they send
those ballots out to people in the mail
like in Maricopa County and [ __ ] Okay
let's listen
a man running for a college District's
governing look at that Maricopa County
that's the other good part
about this is the people uh up there the
last clip from the clean Q Anon voters
USA whatever the [ __ ] their Traders
trees in this uh organizations called
their criminal network of scumbags who
is probably going to go to [ __ ] jail
for crimes that they committed behind
their motives of voter intimidation in
Maricopa County are literally taking
pictures of people dropping ballots in
that box probably voting for a
republican masturbator Randy Kaufman
here for Community College District and
it's probably they're probably dropping
those ballots in that box that they're
taking pictures of because it's not just
Democrats that drop ballots in in drop
boxes
yeah
make it make sense you can't make this
[ __ ] up bored arrested for masturbating
on a campus that's part of the district
he's been running for okay it was a it
was a preschool
it was a it was a preschool
is where he was apparently where he was
parked and he was he was uh
he was beaten off
he was uh waxing the carrot
playing with his PUD you know there's a
lot of names for it right
thank you
let's continue well at first it's
disturbing the actual the report from
the police is disturbing
um and then from a political standpoint
it's it's a game Ender it's so this
guy's saying that there's no way this
guy's gonna win which I you know I don't
know I don't know the [ __ ] Community
College race quite frankly
I have no idea but I I would really
imagine that people aren't going to vote
for a guy who just got caught jacking
off outside of preschool in his pickup
truck for any kind of overseeing or
oversight or administrative and
qualities or anything have to do with I
don't know education probably not a
thing they'll do maybe if it's a really
Republican District maybe like that
qualifies him
he obviously uh knows his genitalia so
he'll know students and he'll know what
bathrooms they're supposed to go in and
CRT it's over Bob Charles is a political
analyst for campaigns and says in the
court of public opinion this is damning
for Randy Kaufman according to the
police report Maricopa County College
police officer found Randy Kaufman with
his pants down masturbating in his truck
at 4 30 in the afternoon in the Rio
Salado college campus the foreign
okay well
um I think I know where Randy went wrong
um Randy dude
um
I don't know how long you've been doing
this you know this masturbating thing
generally speaking you do not have to
have your pants down
right I don't know I don't know exactly
what they mean here but when they say
like pants down a lot it sounds like
down below his knees or some [ __ ] right
what the [ __ ]
that really weird think about this think
about this officer that approaches this
car right now listen to what they say oh
Randy oh dandy Randy says here when the
cops approaches parking lot just feet
away from a preschool and Child Care
Center where kids were outside playing
when confront whoa
whoa dudes whacking it with kids outside
playing in the in the preschool thing
whoa
choking his old chicken while the
children are playing this is weird stuff
and it's on brand for the GOP isn't it
fronted Kaufman told the officer I
[ __ ] up I'm really stressed Kaufman
when
I
mean hey you know when you're stressed
out why not you know um rub one off or
something you know I don't know you know
some people find relief that way but
don't do it in your truck in front of a
preschool Randy Jesus Christ the [ __ ]
wrong with you went on to tell the
officer he worked in the Department of
Corrections for 27 years and was running
for the college's governing board
Kaufman then claimed he didn't notice
the child Center until he got out of his
truck and asked the officer if he was
going to put that in the report
are you are you gonna put the facts in
the report oh God please please don't
put facts in reports that is a thing
that we don't want to do
this dragon guy Jesus the officer
responding don't you see how alarming
that is that there are children nearby I
don't think that anybody that hears this
news and words who have cast a ballot
for him feels good about their their
ballot even though Kaufman was charged
with look at this gang
hey if you're listening to me on the
directories you really gotta come to
YouTube
look at this [ __ ] gay
I mean I'm not trying to you know
make any generalizations here
but you do a little different style of
hair kit and kind of a uh you know what
you would think of
it's a it's a mainly beard you get Matt
Walsh right here right
just saying public sexual indecency on
October 4th the Maricopa County
Recorder's Office says it's too late for
his name to be removed from the ballot
and some people have already voted early
which can't be changed if you already
voted you already voted Randy Kaufman
said you see that if you already voted
you already voted but here's look at
that oh there's the Dropbox
there's someone putting it in there okay
let's let's listen if you already voted
you already voted Randy Kaufman sent me
this statement today announcing he's
suspending his campaign saying a
personal legal matter has recently
Arisen and I need to step out of the
race to focus on personal affairs
oh you gotta be kidding me that's his
excuse listen to this
[Music]
a personal legal matter has recently
arisen
it was erected out of nowhere
it's almost like it was like there's
your personal legal matter for you what
in the actual [ __ ] are you serious they
didn't they did not write that like that
right
what
recently Arisen are you [ __ ] kidding
me I told you this [ __ ] this this is
not real this cannot be real life
this has got to be made up right
Jesus
you just have personal fears that pop up
out of nowhere you gotta take care of
them you know wherever you may be
sometimes these things happen
these problems come out of nowhere and
you just gotta get rid of them as soon
as it gets
arisen
oh [ __ ] let's keep going and I need to
step out of the race to focus on
personal affairs I asked if you wanted
to do an interview with me and he said
not at this time the America I I mean
you're talking about in my truck uh
where would we have this interview would
it be in my truck would it be near a
daycare center because I'm kind of not
allowed to go near those anymore oh my
God Copa County Recorder's Office says
as of Tuesday night Kauffman had not
officially submitted a withdrawal so
even though he says his campaign is
suspended he's still officially in the
race and he's in the race he hasn't
pulled out yet
foreign
[Music]
Charles says this incident may impact
how many people in Arizona end up early
voting I think this causes people to go
okay listen listen to this again this is
one of the best parts of the whole thing
he he absolutely does this on purpose I
can tell by the look on his face he slam
dunks this listen to this to maybe hold
their ballots longer because they'll say
well what about the hold their balance
if you just hold on to it just get a
good grip on it really hard and firm
don't stop holding on
my God there's other candidates what if
something else should pop up
okay that's enough I can't do it anymore
that that's it that's it that's it I
can't do it anymore and what if
something else should pop up about these
other candidates well I don't know I
don't know there's a lot of popping
going on
oh my God this is this is the party of
trump folks this is what you got to work
with
this is it this is it this is it
um like Laura Logan I'm not going to get
to this Laura Logan clip or the Howard
Stern clip I do want to play one more
clip now the president United States
here
um acen has it here I'm not sure who the
reporter is who ask him this but we're
going to end on this note here and the
reporter asks any restrictions on
abortion at all Biden says yes
Biden says yes there is a restriction on
abortion and the reporter says what
should they be
another question
that Joe Biden serves up a great answer
he says Roe v Wade read it man you'll
get educated oh my god listen
dark Brandon just can't stop
disappointing um let me get to this here
I think I believe this is the clip now
it's going to be really hard to hear and
the reason why I'll show you is you see
Marine One in the background and there's
a lot of noise going on because he's
getting on Marine one so this is kind of
just a gaggle right outside the Marine
one where he's getting on now because at
the end here you see he takes off he
starts running
um which you know uh many many
presidents can't do but he starts to run
um when he when he gets in this uh
Marine one he runs towards it he can run
oh my God he can actually get to a gate
here okay so here is um here's the video
isn't loading what the hell is going on
here hang on a second let me go back let
me reload this I think I fast forwarded
the [ __ ] too much
where is it there it is okay
now I got her back
um here's the video again it's gonna be
tough to hear this here
um but you'll hear him ask the question
and give him the answer and he does it
right before he takes off running watch
okay
read it man you'll get educated it's
really simple they we didn't want Roe v
Wade overturned
that what what don't you people
understand about Roe v Wade literally
Roe v Wade is the restrictions
you dumb [ __ ] don't understand
that that Roe v Wade the decision was
actually the restrictions
that was the restrictions it really is
stupid ass [ __ ] that we have to tell
these people this
Roe v Wade was the restrictions on
abortion
huh kind of kind of convenient
okay everybody remember today is
Thursday which makes tomorrow Friday
obviously
and on Fridays though maybe not so
obviously for some of the new viewers we
have bonehead of the week you vote you
decide who is the bone Hen of the week
and me and my co-host and executive
producer Gabe Sanchez break it down in
the second hour every single Friday so
don't forget to subscribe here on
YouTube you're not going to want to miss
a thing you can also vote on YouTube on
the community tab
and you need to go follow us on Twitter
at Tony Michaels pod you can vote for
bonehead of the week there also follow
me at the Tony Michaels and follow Gabe
Sanchez at I am Gabe Sanchez
whatever you do though do not do not go
mention
uh the Soros Medical Group
deep State filming that he was a part of
today do not do not go mention that on
Twitter download every single episode on
Apple Spotify and Google
don't miss a single episode
and while you're there downloading the
episode and subscribing leave us a great
review on that directory also if you're
on Facebook right now if you're on
Facebook right now if you're on the
books of face go over to at the Tony
Michaels follow us on our page there we
broadcast here that live there and we
also put some other videos and memes up
there I've been trying to engage with
people on Facebook I've been trying to
figure it out I haven't done Facebook in
a long time so still trying to figure
the books to face out but I'll get it
down I promise we're also on Twitch
Everyone likes the chat on Twitch so go
check that out also and these these
shirts are flying off the shelves and
everyone it's getting cold out there
don't forget to go check out store dot
Elite tonymichaels.com
store.thetonymichaels.com for the
freedom to oppress the rights of other
people is not Liberty hoodies pullovers
zip UPS we got sweaters t-shirts even
and coffee mugs don't forget to go to
store not d20michaels.com to find your
greatest merch there we appreciate all
your support also you can give us
support by going to tonymichaels.live
Tony Michaels not live you can leave a
tip there one time or you can set it up
monthly
whichever suits your fancy we appreciate
all your support that's how we run here
at the Tony Michaels podcast is on your
support rather it be a you guys grabbing
this great merch and wearing it and
standing in line staying warm while
you're gonna go vote here in a couple
weeks
or you're giving us a tip or the most
important thing is come here every
single weekday
every single one of them
Monday through Friday two full hours and
tomorrow's Friday bonehead of the week
so until tomorrow same time same place
Surf's Up [ __ ]
you've been listening to the Tony
Michaels podcast in your face commentary
of current events and political news no
rules No Boundaries I think we've made
that perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed
the show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow toning on social media
at the Tony Michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[ __ ] them [ __ ] em
[Music]
Murphy's mealborn headass Beacon